okay uh all right welcome everyone we'll
kick off the
third day of this uh rl boot camp
uh the first two days if if you attended
or watched the videos were
uh i hope what what is sort of core rl
from cs
planning online uh offline
uh i hope you've seen uh gotten a good
coverage
the last three days are going to be
disciplinary perspectives from three
disciplines that we feel
are closest to rl uh statistics control
theory
and operations research so today we have
we're very fortunate
to have eric labor from nc state uh
giving us a tutorial on
statistical inference in rl now rl a lot
of roots go back to stats uh including
giants like blackwell and lai and robins
and within our generation uh susan
murphy and eric himself
who got his phd working with susan here
at michigan where i am
and eric has been a real leader in this
field of dynamic treatment regimes which
includes techniques from rl and from
causal influence and from
semi-parametric efficiency theory and
tries to address decision-making
problems in really complex scenarios
that arise
in healthcare especially with high
amounts of noise and
little signal and you have to design
your study carefully and do statistical
inference and build confidence intervals
and and some of the the more uh
statistical topics started to emerge in
emma's talk
in her tutorial yesterday uh when she
was talking about offline data analysis
uh and she also mentioned uh healthcare
and education as application areas
in these areas we don't have simulators
usually we have lots of noise lots of
variability
and i feel like in these domains having
a statistical viewpoint
is even more important than maybe in
some other audio applications
so um so welcome eric
take it away well thanks thanks
everybody for coming and
uh give me the chance to talk here um
[Music]
so in the next day and booze and the
organizers um a lot of this draws from
previous
talks or papers and and so a lot of this
is the work of my students or postdocs
or collaborators
you can learn more about them uh their
bios on my web page
so uh i wanted to start by by giving a
little bit of introduction and
background
and which will also reveal kind of my
own biases so if i make a statement
about that seems very general
it's really only general kind of in the
world i work in and so i hope nobody
takes offense or you know says that's
not really the way it is because it may
be working in an area that i'm not
familiar with
so i'll try not to speak too much in
generalities but i just wanted to sort
of say upfront the kinds of problems i
think about
which frames the way i sort of think
about problems and the way that i
describe them
so my own research focuses on
methodological development
for decision making in really data
impoverished settings so these are these
are generally not high volume settings
or at least they're not the
signal-to-noise ratio is often small
so as ambush mentioned i work on
precision medicine precision public
health
logistics and sometimes so the data
volume is high and i'll go through three
examples uh in a minute
uh the signal may be weak which means
that we still
have substantial uncertainty um and
often collecting more data is not
is not inexpensive um so if you're
talking about a clinical trial and each
data point is a patient that can be
extremely expensive
or for talking about say busy building a
fulfillment center
in the logistics problem also each
decision is very expensive
and so in these areas uh statistical
inferences is critical because there's
so much uncertainty
but also as i'll talk about uh there's a
lot of work now in bringing rl
into more like sort of critical problems
where rl hasn't been used before
and so the reality is that there's some
kind of
a panel of human decision makers who
want to use data
to inform their decisions but they're
not ready to sort of hand complete
control over to some kind of automated
system
and so we need to provide them uh with
uncertainty estimates and give them
confidence and help build trust so that
these systems can be adopted and used in
the real world and so what we're seeing
is that inference is playing you know a
really critical role
uh for getting that kind of buy-in from
domain experts
um so these these images here in the
bottom i'll go through these correspond
to an example
so the first one is kind of a classic uh
biostats example an adaptive clinical
trial or response adaptive clinical
trial
and while i'm mainly going to focus on
inference i want to sort of give the
context
set the stage for some of the methods so
one of the trials we're involved in
uh now is isp2 plus and so this is an
adaptive platform clinical trial for
breast cancer and i realize not
everybody's a clinical trialist and so
what does that mean what it means is
that patients are coming into the trial
and you're assigning them to treatment
with probabilities that adapt
to the evolving uh information so the
accumulating information so you look at
the responses of previous patients
and you look at their biomarkers and you
adapt the probabilities so
the idea is that we want to give you
treatments
we want to be more likely to give you a
treatment that's going to to benefit you
so those working uh well even if this is
all new and you've sat through the
tutorials you'll certainly have heard of
thompson sampling
which was motivated by this very problem
where patients were enrolling and they
wanted to
adjust the randomization probabilities
to two treatments to try to benefit
patients in the trial a platform trial
and this kind of trial in particular
is more complicated in that new
therapeutics are being introduced
and removed from a pool over time so
this becomes a very complicated
uh setting where you are getting
information with the new therapy that
comes in which you have no prior
information or you have some prior
information
and patients are randomized multiple
times
so this is an example of a kind of you
know
a bandit type problem uh but there's
complex dependence across the patient so
they're not really independent
uh as they come in because of the
randomization probabilities and also we
want to do inference we're doing all
this kind of adaptive randomization
uh but inference becomes very
complicated uh so the goal here is to
optimize health outcomes for both the
in-trial patients and the future
patients who would benefit from
information generated by the trial so
this is this kind of duality between
sort of exploiting what you know now and
uh trying to learn so that you can make
better decisions in the future
so the kind of questions that we want to
answer uh you know how to how do
treatments
how should we tailor treatments to the
evolving characteristics of each patient
when if and for whom does a given
treatment work so this is a slightly
different question
so sometimes trials are sponsored by
drug companies and they want to know
is there some subgroup that my treatment
works best for
and you know what patient
characteristics or biomarkers are really
important for choosing treatment so
that's like generating new clinical
insights into a problem
and just to give you a sense for kind of
why this is such a mess
uh on the right the lower right hand
corner here
you can see the sort of schematic for
the trial so you have
this arrow here you have a new agent or
a new therapeutic comes in
that forces you to update randomization
probabilities for new patients we have
new patients coming in
we randomize them either to some kind of
experimental condition or control arm
we observe an outcome we update the
probabilities uh we
have to apply certain termination rules
to remove treatments from trial or to
triage patients into different
salvage therapies so it's very it's very
complicated
uh but also we really have very limited
data and so every decision we want to
make sure we're sort of maximizing
information
sort of accumulation okay so this is
this is one example
uh another one we were asked to look at
how ebola virus
or how resources were allocated in the
ebola virus outbreak in 2014
so this is an example where we're sort
of asked to look back and add a strategy
and do kind of policy evaluation
and so what we're looking at is the
allocation of interventions over both
space and time so down here is a map of
west africa
and i have a color code of the infection
from outbreak which is sort of the stark
this green to red uh and so it starts in
cucado and
spreads out and of course the decisions
you make are subject to logistical
constraints and cost constraints and you
also have imperfect information so there
might be a report that there's
a sort of infections where there aren't
any and of course there are under
reporting and so on
uh and so the kind of questions that we
were looking to answer is how should the
interventions have been tailored to the
evolving pandemic
yeah that's one question and you know is
an rl based intervention
strategy better than an expert strategy
and if so how much better and why
so for those who have followed this
there's been enormous uh
debate about how much was spent in the
management of the outbreak and whether
it was effective or not
and this has real implications for how
we manage infectious diseases now
uh and obviously um this is something we
can't quite ignore in our current
state so um with
yeah with cohort so on okay so this is
another uh sort of example
and then uh i'll talk about two sort of
other examples from industry so this is
um something i work on
i'm an amazon scholar so i spent some
part of my time at amazon
and so one kind of interesting bandit
type problem is bookstore assortment
selection so what books should go in the
stores right
and this of course happens at grocery
stores and it happens basically any
retailer
uh so you can ask okay well you know
what title should go in there and
there's some enormous action space so
there's like a hundred thousand
titles that that are like deemed
acceptable uh and from those you want to
choose something like two to five
thousand depending on the size of the
store
and so you know the set of actions is a
hundred thousand choose
two thousand which is enormous and this
is known as a combinatorial decision
problem
and of course the goal and you can tell
that you know it's important that we
make sure amazon's happy with things
that we say about this about what we do
there so we want to make
customers happy of course but then also
you want to make sure that you are
generating revenue right so the kind of
questions here
uh keeping in mind that in a bookstore
previously these decisions were all made
by people
right so there's these experts that go
into cybergo in the store and of course
there's interest in using rl because of
the benefits it might bring in terms of
just improving utility uh but so obvious
questions like what's the optimal
assortment
and but how does it vary across space
and time how does it vary across
say the northwest versus the southeast
uh and if we use an rl based assortment
how does it differ from expert curators
right so what's
what are the key differences what are
the takeaways and can we push that back
into data-driven decision-making
you know done by by humans and how do we
experiment efficiently and safely by
safely here i just mean
uh without taking too much risk uh you
know if you have a really bad assortment
not only do you have low sales but if
people think the store they go to the
store
they don't see things that they want to
buy they may not come back right so
there's very long-term kind of
consequences
um so this is the kind of uh of question
in books and this is kind of a classic
big you might think about this as a big
data problem in the sense that
you can leverage you know data from com
obviously there's a lot of sales data
there
uh
sorry i should stop i was pausing to
read a question but maybe i'll try to
find a good time to kind of
uh i'll pause after the examples and
answer the question so that i don't just
stare blankly into the screen
um uh and uh another
uh question related to bookstores that
maybe you might not
have thought about or i hadn't thought
about at least so you think about books
where you think about all this data but
there's this other issue which where do
you put the stores
so now we've gone from kind of a big
problem to a very small problem there's
like 10
book stores currently open in the united
states uh and so if we're looking at
what locations to put them do they go to
malls they go on street corners so they
go in big cities they go in suburbs
where should they go
how big should they be um and of course
it's related to the assortment problem
that a good
location requires you you know might
only be good if you choose the
assortment correctly
but now uh we're talking about a very
small
sort of uh number of data points and
every action
requires you to build a store right the
the action is put a store at a given
location
and so now we're talking about you know
a big investment
and a lot of legwork in terms of getting
that in place and getting it constructed
and signing leases and so on
the goal remains the same but now uh you
know we look at the questions like which
subset of available sites should be
chosen so so some set of sites become
available in a given city
uh which one should we should we either
investigate further or go ahead and pull
the trigger and build a store there
what makes that a good location is it
foot traffic is it the number of
uh let's say prime members that are near
the area is it the other stores that are
around
is the type of jobs that people have is
it their age demographic or something
else
um and how do we grow so suppose we
wanted to build more stores of a
particular type or some other company
wanted to do that
how do we how do we optimally grow so we
could build let's say
you know k stores now or we could build
you know k over two stores now and wait
to see
that data and then choose the next k
over two right and there's obvious
trade-offs there
and so there's a lot of problems uh
where we also want to
attach uncertainty to all the answers
that we give to the the human curators
um okay so i wanna i'm gonna just pause
and take the question the question is
you know are the these examples
uh do we find use for inverse
reinforcement learning uh
and you know the idea being there can be
if we observe
the decisions people are making can we
reverse engineer uh
what reward process they were using or
what kind of policy they were following
and that's a
a great question uh
and we do do this um in some
applications we've done this in some
medical decision making
where we take um you know observational
data and we look at decisions that
clinicians are making over time
and we and we try to reverse engineer
what kind of composite
uh outcome they might be trying to
optimize and even if if we think they're
doing it imperfectly try to then bound
with the sort of optimal policy would be
in this context you kind of do this ad
hoc
uh irl where you um you talk to the
people and ask them you know what is
driving your decisions
uh and it's unlikely they're kind of
implicitly solving an mdp in their head
but it is more likely that they are they
are
trying to sort of optimize
uh immediate revenue and then also
you know there is some experimentation
that happens so you might say well
how are local offerings going to do so
should we have a section
on like exploring seattle in a store for
example
and they're they're kind of running
those kinds of experiments so it's
mostly
kind of myopic optimization with maybe a
little bit of
experimenting and so that's kind of hand
crafting
uh you know through human interaction
the the reward function
but that's a great question about what
you should be choosing so you don't end
up optimizing for the wrong thing
so eric i had a question about the first
example of adaptive clinical trials so
you know you mentioned thomson sampling
goes back to 1933 and
and having an adaptive trial just seems
like such a natural idea for a person
who
works with bandits and rl why are they
not as common as one might think like is
it simply the logistical difficulties
that you alleviate
uh so that's a good question so why
aren't they why why aren't they the only
thing we do
uh and there's been a bunch of debate in
in the clinical trials world about the
ethics of doing this
uh in part there's this there's this
idea that well if there's really
equipoise we shouldn't be
changing the probabilities but there's
also this idea that
there's certainly a mentality about
we're going to run a trial for a very
short amount of time with a very short
number a very small number of patients
and then we're going to take that
information and we're going to inform
the decisions we're going to make for
many many many more
patients and so if you imagine that
you know we're going to have 100
patients in a trial but then we're going
to treat let's say 100 000 patients
based on the information we accumulated
then there's this focus on generating as
much information as possible in the
trial
and often the thing that generates the
most information
is uh either you know complete
randomization or adaptive randomization
but adapting for information gain and
not for
exploiting or outcome adaptive
randomization to maximize outcomes
but there has been movement on this in
terms of trying to
formalize that balance because
i think the out of trial patients the
in-trial patients aren't always so
imbalanced as we like to think
another issue is how how challenging
inference is because once you start
adapting the randomization probabilities
to uh the accumulating data then
everything becomes messy
sample size calculation becomes more
more difficult sort of uh
ensuring you have correct inference
becomes more difficult
uh so that those are some of the reasons
um especially with things where like
treatments are coming in and out
but we do know how to do inference for
bandits um so uh at least in certain
cases parametric bandits and so on so
um yeah that's the short answer some
historical reasons and also some ethical
reasons and then there's
uh kind of mental model reasons
okay uh so all these examples you know
we looked at informing
decisions that are typically made by
people uh using reinforcement learning
and so obviously it's been used in in
areas like computational advertising and
robotics and all sorts of uh interesting
areas
but now it's showing up in places where
we haven't used it before so
i'll call these high-stakes problems and
that you know previously
uh in whatever domain humans thought
these problems were too important to
automate uh or maybe they just couldn't
automate
uh and so medicine is an obvious one
precision public health is another one
low frequency business decisions like
opening stores or building like
fulfillment centers or warehouses
uh defense and intelligence is now
getting into this there's some pretty
interesting stuff in terms of like
can you build decision support systems
that would generate things a human
wouldn't have thought of
so uh intelligence
operators are interested in that uh
because they don't want
they don't want a thing that agrees with
them they want to think that we'll tell
them a scenario or generate a scenario
or a decision sort of path
that their opponent might think of or
their you know whoever the adversary is
that they wouldn't have thought
for the adversary there's some
interesting stuff there um
but as we look to transition to rl
decision systems we go to implement
these things
we really have to build trust and that's
that's done by developing knowledge
uh and uncertainty qualification
quantification and so
you know at the heart of that is
statistical inference at least from my
point of view
and so uh having been in these
discussions with clinicians and with
decision makers
and industry and defense
that's really critical to get buy-in if
they're gonna use the things that we
build
okay so that's kind of the motivation uh
here's an outline for the rest and i
also should point out that you know i
have like
basically an infinite number of slides
and so there's i don't expect us to get
through them all
uh but i i kind of said that i was
hoping we'd get through the first part
and then i would selectively talk about
some of the stuff here based on interest
and i also thought it would be useful uh
i would i thought it would also just be
useful to put this all in one place and
so if people were interested in
something i didn't cover they could go
look at the slides
so like a lot of the simulation
experiments uh i may skip over
uh but i wanted to put them in there so
we could see their operating
characteristics
could you say a little bit more on the
low frequency business decision
oh sure so i think uh maybe i should
just say the contrast i'm making so i
think about high
high frequency decisions things like ads
so what ads we display
or um you know what sponsored things do
we display uh and on search
unlike amazon.com uh those kind of
things where you're making many many
decisions
uh and each decision kind of is so so
very high frequency of decisions
recommender systems and so
on but also the cost of any
recommendation
is low that's not to say that that a
small chain doesn't
you know produce enormous volume uh and
it isn't important
but that's different than say building a
warehouse if you're going to build a
i don't know you know one of these giant
100 000 square warehouses
square foot warehouses somewhere uh it's
going to be there for a long time
or if you're going to build a go store
it's filled with all this you know
computer vision tech and very expensive
you know those are those are less
frequent decisions
uh or are treating a patient that you
see once every three months or once
every six months
uh we've done this for like dentistry so
uh you know when should you recommend
that the person comes back to the
dentist
uh surprising that no one had looked at
that before
and that they sort of come back once
every six months recommendation goes
back to like
i don't know i can't remember 1890s or
something it just has never been updated
obviously if somebody has sort of bad
dental health they should come in more
frequently if somebody has good dental
attention less frequently
uh but um even big companies like health
partners
uh don't do that um and so we worked on
that a little bit with them
so that's what i meant hope that helps
uh okay so uh in terms of this outline
i'm gonna start off with this sort of
toy problem uh which is the max of means
this is a well studied problem
statistics goes back to the to the 80s
at least
if not earlier and the reason to look at
this problem is it sets all the ideas so
then as we
as we then look at this at a slightly
more complicated problem which is
inference for the value function
we'll see these ideas propping up and
then as we look at popping up and as we
look at the rest of these
uh we'll see um
uh basically the same ideas just in more
complex settings
uh okay so one one question that came up
here is how do we see implementation of
rl to autonomous
uh critical safety systems
uh i don't know that i have a uh i
haven't worked in an area and i don't
know that i have a strong
opinion there although i will say the
one the one area where we've worked
that where safety is really important is
in diabetes so
if you're looking at you see the
artificial pancreas type work or things
that are making recommendations
for for uh let's say how much insulin to
take or what to eat before you exercise
there's real serious risk there right
for for we work in type 1 diabetes
and so there we have done some work in
rl but
having very tight error controls or risk
of adverse event control so it's kind of
like
neiman pearson type decision making url
uh but i haven't worked in like uh you
know robotics or autonomous vehicles or
some of those things where were
uh there's i know there's been some
innovative stuff in safety but i don't
i don't know much about that area
[Music]
okay so some notes on context for the
rest of this
tutorial we're going to try to pick up
the simplest possible settings to
illustrate the technical challenges
there will be a couple times where i do
a little aside and say okay here's what
would happen if we were
like in an mvp setting instead of a one
decision setting or
um if we had some other kind of
generalization
we're going to look at simple parametric
models uh because those illustrate
really the key points and the idea being
that you can use basis functions or
other kinds of expansions to to go to a
non-parametric model
and we're going to generally in terms of
assumptions we're going to generally
avoid assuming the models are correct
especially since we're using these
parametric models
and so when we talk about inference
we're often talking about projections of
the truth
let's say value function or q function
or something on to whatever space we're
approximating with um
and there will be some regularity
conditions that i'll make implicitly so
if i have an expectation of something
i'll assume that it exists
and so moments and and that param
parameters are identifiable and that say
parameters are in the interior of a
space or something i'll
kind of i probably won't say that but
the references uh will include all the
technical conditions and also
i'm not going to talk about the proofs
unless i think it's particularly
instructive so i only have a handful of
those
but i'll give references to the proofs
because some of these proofs are long
but they're
kind of more the same and so it's not
really instructive to go through them
at least in the time that we have i'm
going to look at distribution theory so
mostly confidence intervals and testing
uh so i won't be discussing uh finite
sample bounds
um there are certainly people on this
call that are much more qualified to
talk about that than i am but also
uh in the applications we're looking at
you know a lot of it is is
really focused on on confidence
intervals and
and testing so is this biomarker
important for making a decision
uh is this a good type of thing to offer
in a store that kind of thing
[Music]
okay uh so the max of means problem and
uh i'm trying to do something here that
uh you know might have been better done
on a board but we're not we're not
together and so
i i may be spending more time on slides
but please ask clarifying questions
because i know these slides are busy
we'll just try to go kind of through
each line at a time one at a time so
so let p be some fixed but unknown
distribution on rp
okay so some some uh p greater than two
because if p is one this is
all pointless and we'll define mu zero
to just be the mean so i'll be using
this operator notation so p of x is just
the expectation of x
uh so it's the integral of x against the
distribution here
and we'll define mu zero to be the max
the component wise max of this mean
vector so there's there's
p means one for each component and we
use this wedge notation for max
so it's just the max of mu01 through mu
zero p
right so uh this shows up in
things like if you have a k arm or in
this case a p arm randomized clinical
trial
you randomize patients to to each of
those p
treatments you take the mean outcome and
then you say well if i pick the one that
has the highest mean outcome
uh then that's which treatment i think
is best if higher is better
and so this would be the sort of
performance of the best
treatment in that case you know but more
importantly it's just a mathematical
kind of toy problem that illustrates all
these ideas that we're going to get into
with with q learning and other
reinforcement learning algorithms
so we're going to assume that we observe
x1 through xn
these are id draws from p so these are
each vector each one of these is a
vector in rp
and mu hat is just a sample mean so i
use this bold pn denote
empirical expectation so it's just an
average over the data such as the
sample mean and then theta hat is just
the max of the sample means
right and so our goal is to make
inference about theta zero
based on theta hat right and typically
inference for theta zero will be based
on the limiting distribution of root n
theta hat minus theta zero and we know
that for nice problems
root n times our estimator minus the s
demand or the truth
uh is normal and we can use that for
confidence intervals or we use the
bootstrap
but it turns out in this case that
doesn't happen
and that's because of this max operator
so i want to i want to first kind of
walk through how one might approach this
problem and why one
encounters problems or difficulties
okay in a 233 slide talk
there's a lot of letters to be used so
apologies in advance for using factor
but
that's what we had to do here so uh so
some vector nu in rp defined factor u of
nu to be the set of maximizers of of
this vector
okay so it can contain more than one
element if we have no unique
maximizer okay so here's the the first
thing
uh so let's assume that we have
sufficient irregularity conditions that
p n minus p times root n times x is
normal so that is
so just if this notation's unfamiliar
and this is just
the sample mean minus the true mean
scaled by rho n so it's just
you know in other notation it might be x
bar minus mu times root n is normal
right so this is true you know as long
as you have second moments
uh so this is a very this is the nicest
statistical problem that we have right
it's just
the sample mean minus the true mean if
suppose that's true
then if we look at root n times theta
hat minus theta zero it converges
to the max over the set of maximizers mu
zero
of these zjs where zj has the same
distribution as
the same loading distribution as x bar
so it's normal mean zero
uh variance covariance sigma okay
uh so i'm actually going to go through
uh the proof of this
just um because i think it's
maybe it's helpful um
it's only one line or two lines so uh
to see why this is true let uh script en
just be the indicator that you made a
mistake so it'll be one if you've
if the maximizer of your sample mean is
not one of the maximizers of the true
mean so
in particular it's an indicator that the
max over k
in that sorry k not in the set of
maximizers over mu zero
over the sample mean is in fact bigger
than uh
the max over uh the set of maximizers mu
zero
of the sample mean that is if you take
the arg max and sample mean you won't
get a maximizer of the true mean so
you've made a mistake
uh then you can show that this is a
little op1 why because there's only p of
these things and there's a gap between
the
maximizers their mean and the everything
else and so eventually you'll figure
that out
and you won't make any any mistakes uh
so if we write down
theta hat minus theta zero uh we can
write it as
the max of root n mu hat minus theta
zero
if uh you get it right or
this difference if you get it wrong so
if you just look at this for
for a minute and you'll see that if this
thing is one
then this term here you guys can see my
mouse is that right
yeah i can i can see your question yes
okay yeah great
so this term here will just cancel with
this term you'll be left with this so if
you make a mistake
uh you'll be maximizing over the wrong
sets the set that doesn't maximize mu0
and if you don't make a mistake you'd be
maximizing over the set of maximizers so
you get this term
so this is just uh these two things are
equal
but what's convenient about this form is
that we know this term is a little op
one and this term here is bounded
uh by mu hat minus mu zero if we take
the sum of mu hat minus mu zero absolute
value times root n
uh that'll be an upper bound on this you
can just use the triangle inequality
to get that so what you end up with is
the max
over this first term
and i use the fact that when j is in
this set of maximizers
theta 0 is in fact the same is the jth
mean
these two things are equal because j is
a maximizer
so you just get red n times mu hat minus
its mean
and then you have the max and the
outside plus some term it goes to zero
and so this thing here is going to
converge to
uh the limit we stated uh in right so
this thing will go to
go to normal but all these could all the
components over j will go jointly to a
normal then we'll take this max
to use continuous mapping theorem so uh
the idea is that we get this limit but
it depends on this
set right with the set which we don't
know
uh and so what can we do about this and
why is it why is this even a problem
okay so it tells us that
root n theta hat my state of zero goes
to this max of zj well we can certainly
estimate zj
the problem is we don't know this right
and the limiting distribution depends
abruptly on mu zero in the sense that
uh if we change mu zero by a little bit
we can change this limit a lot so for
example if p
is two so there's just two means uh and
suppose that
uh they are equal so they're both equal
to zero so the arc max is two components
and suppose that sigma is just the
identity so everything's independent
then the limit would be the max of two
independent normals that would be the
limiting distribution here
but if instead we change the true
generative model to be zero and epsilon
where epsilon is some arbitrarily small
number like let's say 10 to the minus 20
then the limit the asymptotic limit
would be standard normal
so if we wanted to use
maybe i should say this too also which
is
uh which is that why do we care about
asymptotic approximations at all
we care about asymptotic approximations
because we want to make inference
uh for this thing we want to estimate
the finite sample distribution of this
quantity so we can do in make inference
for theta zero that's why we care
so if this thing does not faithfully
reflect the sampling distribution of
this thing
uh then we can't uh construct confidence
intervals or do tests that have the
correct operating characteristics
okay so what is it what does this tell
us here
it tells us that one asymptotic
approximation is a max of two normals
the other one is a standard normal
and the difference uh you know depends
on this arbitrarily small
constant uh epsilon and so that's really
problematic which one should we use
right so the asymptotic distribution
depends on the maximizers but it doesn't
depend on the gaps but intuitively it
should depend on how close those two
means are to each other or in general if
you have p means how close they are
clustered to the maximizer
and this is really problematic because
the finite sample behavior of this thing
will depend critically
on how big the gaps are between the
means and i'll show that in the next
slide
but there's a question that came in that
said uh here i'm assuming that
am i assuming the dimension is fixed yes
so for illustration we're assuming the
dimension is fixed
uh there you can look at the um
uh p diverging with n case uh
and things can just get worse
essentially uh
well okay i should say it depends on how
things diverge but you can imagine a
case where like you keep getting a
piling up of
means getting closer and closer to the
maximum and so
uh whatever problems arise here will
certainly arise there
uh but you'll have additional complexity
um
in terms of estimating the means for
example i mean let's get a question
uh yeah yeah so i'm really wondering
about how serious is this problem
uh in the finite sample case because it
seems that what's happening is
and this is kind of typical that if
you're taking a limit
in one of the variables then you see
some
phase transition like some really sharp
transition happening
but if you're not taking the limit and i
i assume that everything is much
smoother
um yeah so this is a good question
so uh well um
two things one i'm gonna i'm gonna show
you an example on the next slide with
the finite sample behavior
uh so um in normal problems
in standard problems that's exactly what
happens in that
things are smooth and we don't have an
abrupt change in the limit and so
things work out but here we do this
abrupt change is not is not
um it's not something we normally see in
a regular
statistic and we'll formalize that in a
minute
but the the issue is that um
if we wanted to do an uh so you might
say okay well i don't want to use this
directly maybe i just want to bootstrap
this thing
and if i just bootstrap this maybe that
will work right the idea is if this
finite sample thing is smooth maybe i
can bootstrap it or somehow perturb it
and do inference if i don't want to try
to use the actual asymptotic
approximation
uh we'll see that that doesn't work
either but the reason that this is
problematic is we have to use some limit
to make inference
so the natural thing to use then would
be to set would be
to to assume a unique maximizer i think
so you have to pick this set to do
inference right if you're going to use
this approximation
we can definitely estimate sigma right
we can estimate sigma by the sample
covariance that's no problem so then we
have to then use this
if we're going to use an aston
approximation we have to use these
things which means we have to pick
something for this
so a natural thing is to pick this as as
just a singleton and use a standard
normal
we'll see that doesn't work very well uh
and and if you otherwise you have to
kind of guess at a set
which then becomes more difficult
whether you're going to pick say well if
just two maybe just say they're both
maximizers but if you have
ap there's more difficulty yeah yeah so
so i guess what you're saying is that
uh standardly we like to rely on
asymptotics
uh even in the finite sample regime
trusting that somehow the asymptote is
going to kick
in uh anyways soon enough and
that's good and and even bootstrapping
is going to rely on
something like that unless you apply
some really big
corrections uh but those are like really
technical and challenging and to keep
the coverage
uh good it's it's gonna be very very
challenging so all together what this
means is that
uh the standard tools and standard
reasoning
is not really a good fit for this uh
that's what you're saying
that's right yep and and yeah exactly so
yeah thank you and and i'm even going to
show you
what happens if we do this uh now
um yeah great thank you so
uh so let's look at an example suppose
we have um
uh data from a from a normal
distribution mean mu zero
and identity covariance so their
components are independent
and we'll assume that mu0 in fact has a
unique maximizer so this is a setting
where
we have a unique maximizer which means
that if you go back to this
this would just be a singleton and a
limit would be it would be normal
uh i shouldn't yeah okay the limit would
be normal uh
and we'll assume that just for
notational convenience that the biggest
one is mu 1 and it's greater than mu j
so first because everything is normal we
can actually work out what's the cdf the
finite sample cdf of this thing
right so if everything is normal then
then the probability that rho n theta
minus theta 0 is less than t is the cdf
of a standard normal that's what its
asymptotic limit will be times the
product from j equals 2 to p of t plus
root n theta 0 minus mu 0. so this is
going to be that gap
and so the issue here is that as you can
see that this gap here is positive so as
n goes to infinity this thing goes to
infinity each of these terms goes to one
and we in fact get this as our limit
but this can be very far from the
asymptotic limit theta t when the gaps
are small relative to root n
right so these things here could be
non-trivial right
um and so uh
they can contribute substantially to
this limit and if we look at a simulated
example so here i said p equal to 6
n equals 100 and i said mu 0 j to be the
maximizer minus delta
and i have three different values of
delta here delta equals 0.5 0.1 and 0.01
and the histogram of just the actual um
finite sample distribution of theta hat
minus theta 0 times root n
the red line is a standard normal which
is the limit
and you can see that if this gap is big
0.5 so we'd have power like 0.9999 to
detect this difference
uh then this asymptotic approximation
does great so we could we could
construct a confidence interval for
theta 0 based on this
normal limit be no problem but if i
change it to something where i have
lower power
i think the power here is about 0.5 uh
although i should check so i don't quite
remember
now you see this big shift and so if you
look over here we have this
well as expected the max has positive
bias and so it's shifted upward
uh the sampling distribution is shifted
upward and so we could end up with very
poor operating characteristics if we
tried to get a lower quantile for
example
here and of course if he said this to be
really small uh
then then you know and if we went to the
extreme case we could make those almost
non-overlapping of course they'd have to
overlap because the normal distribution
but
uh essentially the amount of overlap
could go uh to zero
and so what this means is that if we
just take the note so here's an n equals
100
and if we took a normal approximation
which is actually the correct limiting
distribution the finite sample behavior
does not match the limiting behavior
and so we have this big mismatch and so
that that's that's
the problem so if we constructed the
confidence interval using this case here
our coverage might be quite far from
nominal levels
i hope that helps uh chava so drive this
point home
so uh okay
so this is what we would call a fixed
parameter asymptotic uh
evaluation or or analysis meaning that
we fixed theta zero
and then we took limits and the problem
here is that
uh it doesn't account for uncertainty
in in factor u of mu zero doesn't it
count for uncertainty in this arg max
set we don't know what this set is
uh but in in the limit in asymptopia
uh we know this set with probability one
meaning that that
we can test whether mu zero j is equal
to the maximizer
uh with power going to one as n diverges
and so there's this mismatch between the
asymptotic framework which says we will
know what that set is
and the finite sample behavior says we
don't know what that set is
uh and we need we need some kind of
asymptotic framework that retains this
uncertainty or this instability about
the set
as n diverges so we want an astronautic
framework that
will allow us to incorporate this
uncertainty and identify sensitivity to
this uncertainty
and the way that this is done uh is
using what are called moving parameter
or local parameter asymptotics and the
idea
is we want to have a sequence we want
our methods to work under a sequence of
generative models
uh where the features of the sampling
distribution are retained asymptotically
what i mean is
uh we want this instability but the
argument set to to sort of persist no
matter how big n gets
and this is a common thing we see when
you study the power of hypothesis tests
we know that
any reasonable hypothesis tests of power
going to one so how do we compare them
we look at sequences of parameters
approaching the null
and the same idea is happening here as
we look at
sequences of parameters that are getting
closer and closer to the max
and you know more generally we're going
to look at one over n perturbations
of the underlying generative model and
we'll study the behavior of say an
asymptotic approximation under such
perturbations
so to do that we're going to look at an
iid draw say xn1 through xn so for every
end we get an ied draw of size
n but now it's from a distribution p n
that changes with n
and we're going to assume that uh the
mean under this distribution p
n uh which we'll write as p n of x is
the mean under p
plus s over root n so this is called the
local parameter
and so it's it's in a local neighborhood
a one overrun neighborhood of mu zero
but as
n uh increases uh then we'll get closer
and closer to mu zero so the idea here
is that we can have a unique maximizer
mu zero uh and we also have a new
unique maximizer for pn but we also have
that the
that some of the near maximizers are are
going to stay within one of rhoda
neighborhoods so our power to detect
them or to take a difference between
those near maximizers
and maximize maximizers never goes to
one that's the idea
and we'll define theta zero n to be just
the max
of mu zero n okay as before i apologies
for the triple subscript
i try not to do that too often um okay
so this is we're gonna now look at what
happens under this
this kind of uh sequence degenerative
models as a way of studying
asymptotic approximations in this
context so eric just
just so that uh it's it's here i'm just
a little bit confused so the
uh the problem you mentioned was was
occurring with sort of the natural
estimator which is just
a plug-in right just plug the individual
estimates into the max
and i'm assuming that you cannot just
get away from the problem by somehow
redefining the estimator but just wanted
to be
clear that that is the case yes that's a
great question in fact i have it as an
faq at the end of this thing
so at the end of this section i have
faqs and that's one of them it's like
well maybe
maybe we just shouldn't use an estimator
maybe we should do something else right
and it turns out the problem is with the
s demand and so there's no avoiding this
problem
yeah that's a great question um
uh okay so what happens if we if we look
at things from this lens to the moving
parameter sort of uh framework and that
should say that this is
um this is commonly done in
as i mentioned statistics for
non-regular problems and testing
econometrics for weak identifiable
problems weekly identifiable problems
and so on
and it can reveal when there's real when
there's issues
and so what what it does it allows us to
have these gaps between the maximum
and the other means to shrink with a
sample size so that we have uncertainty
about this set no matter how big n gets
so uh let's look at the same lemma under
this now moving
parameter asymptotic framework so let s
be fixed that's the local parameter
and uh assume for every n
that these x and i are drawn i
id from pn and that they satisfy this
condition so the the mean under this
distribution the sequence of
distributions p n is the mean under p
plus a local perturbation and we also
assume that written p
n minus sorry the empirical expectation
minus p n of x so the sample mean minus
the true mean
under pn also converges to a normal so
things like the mean are insensitive to
local perturbations
uh that's why they're they're called
regular uh
quantities and so this holds again under
the second moments this is a very weak
condition here
and if you want to convince yourself
just take data from a normal
distribution and take the sample mean
minus the true mean under a model like
this and you'll see
that this local parameter cancels and it
doesn't depend on the local parameter
but if we look at the limiting
distribution of theta hat minus theta
zero under this model
uh then when it converges to i'm sorry
this should be theta zero n apologies
there theta zero n here
is we get the max of zj plus the local
parameter minus the max to the local
parameter so we see is this local
perturbation now shows up in the limit
right and so what that means is the the
asymptotic
which we already knew but the asymptotic
approximation is sensitive to local
perturbations of the generative model of
size 1 over root n
and that's important because if we use a
plug in estimator
we're plugging in say mu hat in place of
mu
and mu hat is like a one over root n
perturbation of mu so
normally when we use plug-in estimators
uh we plug in our estimate you know in
place of the true parameter
but the idea is they're insensitive to a
little bit of of
uncertainty and so everything works out
but here it's saying if you perturb the
true parameter value by
a small amount a one over root n uh
amount
then then the limiting distribution
changes dramatically and that's exactly
what we're trying to do by plugging in
mu hat in place of mu in that max
right so this is why plug-in estimators
don't work for non-regular problems
because
it's sensitive to the kind of
perturbations uh
the kind of uncertainty that's in the
estimated parameter which normally we
wouldn't have
so the fact that this s shows up in the
limit
tells us this is a non-regular problem
so the definition of a non-regular
problem is one in which
uh the local parameter shows up in the
asymptotic limit
so that's that's actually the definition
but this is what signals to us that
there's a big problem in terms of using
like a normal approximation or the
bootstrap and that those things are
going to be inconsistent
so suppose we wanted to do inference so
what's the idea now so the idea is we
want
to conduct inference for theta zero but
we wanted to give correct coverage under
models of this form
and the idea is that if we do that if we
can show that we we
give correct say coverage or correct
operating characteristics for a test
under these models
and we're insensitive to these
perturbations then it will perform well
in small samples because it will become
it'll be insensitive to small
perturbations again and it'll be like a
regular problem
so we want to design inference methods
that are deliver the correct coverage or
operating characteristics under these
kinds of models
that's that's the idea so how do we do
that
well so uh i kind of i think i said all
this already so here's our limit
so it depends on the local parameter s
that's the definition of non-regular
uh and this is what signals we're going
to get poor performance from a standard
asymptotic approximation based on fixed
parameters
and bootstrap and series approximations
are invalid meaning they don't converge
the quantiles won't converge so
inference will be incorrect if you don't
modify them somehow
and this kind of problem shows up
everywhere in decision problems because
we always have this max operator
so uh i know that we saw stuff in
bandits and on mdps
uh and so you know if you think about
the bellman optimality equations there's
this max in there
uh we saw that in this very toy problem
it's very simple toy problem you have a
max of means
uh and so anywhere you're making a
discrete decision
you you are you commonly encountered
this problem i should say
so how do we conduct uh inference
procedures that are valid under the
moving parameter astrotics and the
simple problem with the idea that we can
then generalize them to more complicated
problems which we'll do in the remainder
of the
workshop or the tutorial
maybe perhaps naive question so why is
the negative non-regularity defined in
terms of what happens under the local
parameter setting why not just say that
you have some non-differentiability why
why is there not a simpler definition of
non
regularity is that am i missing
something based uh
oh so so i don't know the motor so that
that the definition comes out of some
parametrics this is how they define it
because i think
in general if this happens you don't
have this nice regular asymptotically
linear expansion of like sum of
influence functions
you don't have that kind of expansion
when this happens and so
uh i don't know if that was the the
right
choice i mean there are there are uh
they're one in the same in the sense
that if you have a non-differentiable
uh functional you can't construct a
regular estimator
uh so but i think there are also
settings where it's not so much
um that the function okay maybe this is
the reason
uh the reason that to define it this way
is to consider something like the lasso
if we have the lasso and the s demand is
the is the coefficient indexing the
linear model
that that that coefficient vector is not
a non-differentiable functional
derivative model it's a nice
functional right but once you put that
penalty on there and we start talking
about
you know putting a lambda hat here and
this is a lasso estimator
now the limiting distribution of that
thing will be sensitive to sj
so uh which then you might think this
contradicts your previous question which
is
that the lasso is an example where you
could choose a different estimator
and get a regular right this ols
estimator would be an example right
that's a regular
estimator behaves nicely the max of
means the problem arises with the s
demand and you can't choose a different
estimator but that's one reason
because sometimes the choice of
estimator will make this non-regular
yeah
so yeah good question um
i don't know if they were anticipating
all of that but the definition comes out
of semicolometrics anyway anyway
at least that's where i first saw it um
okay so what's the simplest thing that
you can do uh well this is a sort of
building block idea which is often a
starting place for making
for developing inference procedures and
that is a projection interval or
production confidence set
so we want to use the fact that mu zero
remember mu zero is just the mean
that's a nicely behaved uh parameter
right that's that's the easiest kind of
that's the first thing we learned about
in statistics
so we know that that thing's nicely
behaved and we also know that theta 0 is
just a function of this
this nicely behaves uh parameter right
so the idea is maybe we can do our
inference for mu0 and then kind of
propagate it back through and that's
exactly
what a projection set does so
uh in particular a prediction confidence
set for the max of means
is constructed by first uh constructing
a one minus
alpha times a hundred percent say
confidence region for mu zero
and you can do that with just a wall of
interval so here i've just given a wall
type confidence interval
set of mu such that n times mu-hat minus
mu transpose
this is uh the estimated covariance
inverse times mu-hat minus mu is less
than some
let's say chi-squared distribution the
percentile of a chi-square distribution
so you you get a wall type region from
mu0 and this thing is nicely behaved it
contains mu zero with probability one
minus alpha
uh both under under the uh fixed and
moving parameter asymptotics again
because the mean is nicely behaved
so then what you do is you say okay well
i have this common sense for the means
i'll take every vector in that
confidence set for the mean
and then i'll just take the
component-wise max of it and then i'll
take the union of all those
uh and so that's a projection set for
music for theta zero
so gamma n one minus alpha is going to
be this confidence set for theta zero
and that'll just be the set of thetas
and r
such that theta is the maximizer the
component-wise maximizer for some vector
mu
where mu is in this confidence set
and uh to see why this will in fact give
you correct coverage whether you're
looking at local or
or fixed parameter asymptotics uh we
just need to work out how we can make a
mistake
so um again this is one of the very few
proofs it's only one line so
it seems like it might be feasible to go
through it so
the error of the set is well that's the
probability that theta zero is not in
our confidence set
well how can that happen well it cannot
be in our confidence set
and our mean might not be in our
confidence region for the mean
or it's not in our confidence set and
the mean is
in uh our confidence region for the mean
right so
uh let's look at the uh second case
first
so if mu zero is in this confidence
region then this can't happen
right theta zero has to be in this
region why because
that would be mu zero is here which
would mean that the
component-wise max of mu zero is here
which means theta zero is in the set
this can't happen so this is this term
here is zero and now that leaves us with
this first term
and this first term is bounded above by
just the second
component right the probability of a and
b is less than the probability of b so
we'll just look at the probability of
this
that's just less than equal to the
probability mu 0 is not in its
confidence region but that's a standard
nicely behaved confidence region so
its error probability is less than alpha
plus little p1 or also a little opn of
one either one
so uh we get correct coverage under both
local and fissa
fixed asymptotics right
so the pros and cons in terms of these
kinds of sets well first of all it's a
great starting point so if you can work
this out then often you can
develop more refined uh sharper type
results
but it's robust uh it's general it's
conceptually simple i mean you're able
to prove it in one line
the problem is the cons this is kind of
a pro but the con is that that it's
minimally adaptive in the sense that
it doesn't really rely in any way on how
big these gaps are
the gaps and the components here right
it just uh takes this
this big union regardless of how well
separated the maximizer is
and that means it can be extremely
conservative in some settings
uh and so you know in some in some toy
problems you can sort of show that this
is going to be you know
twice as large uh uh as
a sort of bootstrap based interval in a
setting where you've done this but you
could have used a bootstrap interval
so a natural question then is well how
do we how do we improve on this
well another idea is to use bounds so
the idea here is we take something like
the max of means or we take something
else that's that's non-smooth or
non-regular
and we just sandwich it between two
regular things and those regular things
we can bootstrap use normal
approximations and do inference for and
if we can get the quantiles or the
bounds
they have to bounce they have to be
quantiles they have to bound the
quantiles for the thing that you're
bounding right uh so maybe i said it
better here in this bullet this will
sandwich the non-smooth functional or
the thing like the max of means
between two smooth bounds and then use a
bootstrap or series approximation on the
bounds
and these bounds are going to be
constructed by taking a soup or an in
for
local perturbations so the idea is if we
want something to be insensitive to
local perturbations a natural way to get
that
is to just take a super and info over
all the local perturbations and then it
has to be insensitive
by construction right and i realize
we're running out of time i only have a
couple more slides in this section and
maybe we can stop
there for our break would that be okay
we ran just a tiny bit over
yeah a few couple minutes okay
so these will be valid under moving
parameter frameworks just by
construction
and they have to be the smallest
possible among the regular bounds in the
sense that you could always construct a
sequence of local perturbations to
attain the super the inf
so you can't really be any smaller uh in
that sense
and they'll also be necessarily adaptive
because if the thing that you're
bounding
is regular meaning it doesn't depend on
the local perturbations then it would be
a regular bound on itself
and you just end up resorting to like a
bootstrap or a normal approximation
so uh what does that look like here uh
and again let's go slow i know this is a
busy slide
so what we're going to first do is we're
going to define a conservative meaning
overly inclusive
uh estimator of the set of our maxes of
mu zero
and we'll do that by just taking the set
of j such the max
over k of mu hat k so it's the sample
max minus mu j
over some estimate of the covariance is
not too big
so basically you say if mu j is within
some tolerance
of the maximizer and you just choose
this tolerance to be conservative
then this should include uh fracture
u of mu zero with high probability uh
and so taiwan is some tuning parameter
goes to infinity and it's little p root
n
and sigma hat is an estimator of this
variance term okay
and now we're going to define a set of
local perturbations say s script
s hat n of mu0 and this is going to be
the set
of vectors in rp such that sj is forced
to be mu zero
j if it's not in our conservative set
okay uh now
this of course is nothing we know but
we'll get to that in a second so then an
upper bound on root n theta hat minus
theta zero
the super for all s in the set of
mu hat minus mu 0 plus sj minus sj and
the way that you get this
is just verification question
k here it says like we're kind of
getting a gap is that right because
these are the different
um different means so okay oh you're
right sorry that should be k equals one
to p
i should have written that out you're
right that's exactly right so it's
basically looking at the difference
between the maximizer the sample mean
and then
uh oh this would be hat that's what was
confusing that's my mistake there should
be a hat here let's see if i can draw it
there should be a hat
between um the empirical gaps basically
yep that's it yeah
hat right there yep thanks sorry
yeah good point so that should be a hat
yeah that was probably very confusing so
there should be a hat there
uh and then the upper bound uh is
the soup over these perturbations of uh
mu hat minus mu zero plus sj minus the
max of sj so some things to note here
if i just set sj to be mu zero j
then they cancel out and i get the max
the sample means minus the max of the
means
right so by taking this soup uh as long
as the soup contains mu zero then this
has to be an upper bound
you'll also notice that that if i bring
this root n in here
and recognize that when s is not
constrained it can be
all in all r sj can be at all of r we
end up with what's going to look like
the limit under local perturbations this
term here will go to
a once i scope at red end we'll go to a
normal and then i'll have kind of a
local parameter here and here
so it's as if i'm taking the soup over
local perturbations
so this thing it turns out because of
the taking this this
soup here and i'm going really wild with
this pen uh
is smooth and you can bootstrap it so
uh if we go to
oops to me i can't advance the slide
while i'm uh
drawing hand
okay let me go here uh that's what this
says
uh if u hat b is the one minus alpha
percentile of u hat and you construct a
lower bound by taking an in
in call l hat b the alpha over two
percentile of the lower bound of l hat
then in fact this is a valid confidence
interval here
uh four theta zero where you basically
looks just like a standard confidence
interval you have the estimator
minus uh quantile estimator minus the
quantile scale by red n
and you can show that this is in fact a
one minus alpha one
times one hundred percent constant over
theta zero and so that super if smoothes
out this uh
uh non-smooth functional and you end up
getting correct coverage
so uh
some comments here uh this set allows
perturbations that are only near the uh
for the near maximizers and that's
important because
uh we're not sort of affecting the the
unimportant parts we don't want to be
conservative in the parts that that
aren't near that maximizer
and this is very similar at least in
spirit to the idea of a pretest
in weekly identifiable problems in
econometrics so if you're familiar with
that literature
they use very similar ideas we also
notice a local parameter
only appears in components that are near
the maximizers because we only want the
soup and if to affect those
uh and what this means is the super in
if adaptively smooths
uh root n theta hat my state of zero
thereby making it regular
an alternative to bounding and taking
quantiles is to try to bound the
quantiles directly
and this is an interesting idea ian
mckig has done a little bit of this
uh he's in the bios department columbia
for testing problems
and that's in general can be less
conservative but it's also much harder
to do
um and
uh finally in terms of discussion before
i go to some faculty
the thing to remember here the take home
message is that this non-smooth max
causes instability
and if we just use fixed parameter
asymptotics this can provide
poor approximations to the finite
sampling distribution which means it's
hard to construct
reliable inference procedures if you
look at a local or moving parameter
asymptotic framework
this more faithfully captures this
instability as the sample size grows
large
this makes it much more reliable if we
want to construct confidence intervals
and b tests
projection and bound based sets are two
procedures that remain valid under local
parameter asymptotics
and we'll see those again and again as
we start to look at at some more
uh examples um
so uh i just had a few faqs if that's
okay or should we stop into the faqs
after the break
so i think officially we can stop so
that people who have to leave and get a
break we can leave
but we can keep chatting i'm i'm still
hanging around
okay so i i said if you have any
questions on discord or on zoom so i
don't think there are any
direct questions okay so here's a uh
good well here's the question i thought
sometimes get asked in this area uh and
i think also just reflects some
confusion
in the literature so the first question
already was already asked by abuja
you know are there methods for inference
that remain valid
for non-regular problems uh oh no sorry
you guys the next one um so are there
other things besides bounding and
predictions yes so things like the mrbn
bootstrap and subsampling
are common
the one thing i think that's a real
practical difficulty with these
kinds of problems is that they're very
difficult to tune because the
the subsample size is only sort of
guided asymptotically
and there's some cases where if you try
to use the m out of n bootstrap it makes
things worse
so there's an interesting paper by
richard samworth 2003
looking at the hottest estimator
and are there any situations where you
would need to use projection confidence
set instead of the bound based
uh i tend to favor the
bound based procedures uh
because they they're often less
conservative uh
but there's some instances where it may
be very hard to construct a bound
i think especially if it's implicitly
defined as an estimator
so that may be a case although i will
talk about one case like that so
generally i
oh there is one case yeah there's
another case which is
uh if you're trying to do sample size
calculation
then sometimes the projection based
interval is easier because
you're talking kind of before the trial
is run and so you want some kind of
a smooth functional of the model that's
easier to handle in fact so i will show
an example like that if we get to it
um another faq
so why can't i just replace the smooth
mounts with quantity with a smooth
approximation so maybe instead of a max
use a soft max or i use bagging or sub
bagging to smooth things out
uh and so can i do this yes but not
really
uh so one of the earliest approaches for
inference for the test error in
classification which has an indicator in
it so it's not smooth
uh or the marginal mean outcome of a
treatment regime was to replace the
indicator with a sigmoid or some other
kind of
you know s-shaped function either by
just plugging in
a sigmoid or by estimating with bagging
or sub-bagging
but what you find is that the bias
that's induced by the smoothing is is
really not negligible
and driving the bias down so that so
uh so that doesn't dominate either
inflates the variance or destroys local
uniform convergence
uh and so this is this came up earlier
is that it's important to note that in
this case the problem is the s demand
and not the estimator
so there's these impossibility results
that show that you cannot construct
a uniformly convergent estimator of the
sampling distribution for a non-smooth
functional
uh and so there's this work by hirano
and porter 2009-2012 vanderhardt has a
nice paper 1999.
uh dos and seth ramen have this like one
and a half page paper where they show
this
thing where the variance has to go to
infinity if you try to drive the bias
down
um so uh that that's that's
the answer there so then another thing
is uh that has come up recently
is and it's been just been some work on
this uh
where people have tried to do the
following thing and so this is this is a
strong opinion as opposed to maybe uh
i just should qualify that way so why
don't we just pick a different s demand
so why don't we just say
i don't care about the max i care about
the soft max or i care about some other
kind of smooth surrogate
and the reason is uh because those
estimates often are interesting or
relevant from a scientific point of view
so
if if a clinician is going to take the
max of those means and use it and we
want to know how
you know what its operating character
characteristics are its uncertainty is
then that's what we need to do inference
for so i think that's on us uh
to to figure out how to quantify
uncertainty not to change the estimate
of something that's statistically more
convenient
uh and so uh
i guess that's maybe i could be debated
others may have different opinions but i
feel strongly that we should
pick the s demand based on the science
the domain and then and then work out
how to do the answer and
de-quantification
um okay so uh another
related faq here is that okay in real
life i know that no two means are equal
so that argument set is really a
singleton so it's just non-regularity
just some kind of mathematical novelty
and i hope i've convinced you that
that's not the case
non-regularity signals that the
underlying estimate is sensitive to
small
and i say non-identifiable meaning you
could you can't
you you can't identify them from the set
from the amount of data you have
in the generative model so that
asymptotic approximations
are poor and or could be porn for small
samples so in our example we had a
unique maximizer
so you know that set was a singleton but
we saw the asymptotic approximation was
poor
as it failed to account for gaps in the
means which were really critical to the
finite sample behavior
and it's interesting to note that the
same kind of thinking occurred in model
selection
where there's this idea that if we have
the oracle property meaning we identify
the set of important variables
and that the sort of limit distribution
of the estimator is the same as if we
had known that set ahead of time then we
could just do inference
but uh we know now of course that that
and it's been known for a very long time
that that performs very poorly because
you don't know the set of important
variables and finite samples and that
uncertainty is enormous so there's this
huge
kind of set of papers by potter and
leave about this
it was known before that also but now
there's this whole industry sort of
around
uh you know inference after model
selection but it's the same that was the
same kind of thinking well if we figure
out eventually
and we have a normal approximation then
everything should work out but we know
in finite samples that it's um that's
not the case
okay so i think uh we'll break there and
then uh
sorry for running over but i just want
to get to the next part
um 1 30 or uh
nine yeah 1 30 eastern and uh whatever
it's uh
10 30. okay
awesome thanks there is one question on
discord
uh eric um if you have to take a break
you can take a break i can ask you later
no i can answer it no sure uh the
question is uh
what is exactly the conservative
conservatism
of the projection method is it really
the somehow the the degrees of freedom
coming from a chi squared or or like you
said it's conservative but it
and it doesn't adapt to the gap in the
means but maybe did you say anything
more about how bad it really is uh
yeah the the in that case it's not so
bad but there are cases where it really
is quite poor
and i think part of the reason is that
um
uh i think maybe i'll draw a picture
um maybe one thing that kind of happens
uh let's try this okay so suppose i have
like
you know i have a i have a joint
confidence region like this for two
parameters
right okay and i want a confidence
interval for
this this parameter here so let's just
say this is like theta
i'm not an artist sorry okay
right but let's suppose i have a pretty
good guess what alpha is i think alpha's
here and i plug it in
and then i say okay well here's my
here's my plug-in estimator for a
confidence interval right so
it ends up being something like this
okay all right
but if i take a union i end up with
something like this
sorry there you go so it ends up being
much wider
in general and this kind of thing
happens in higher dimensions yes i think
part of the question which i forgot to
say is
the question was also like can i take
the union somehow
take the union differently to get away
from the problem
you can and we will and just like three
slides oh okay
good yeah yep uh
another question here is uh is the max
of means typically the right goal in
practice uh when is the max
median or worst case performance ah so
uh i think the max of the means um
i picked is a toy problem that just
illustrates a bunch of the
a bunch of the problems we're going to
see in the later sections uh
as opposed to something that kind of
shows up
commonly i mean it does show up if you
were taking the max
because if you if you took the maximizer
of the means as your selected treatment
then that's that would be a of interest
but i also should say that um
i picked it because it's going to show
up in the value function and the q
function and other things and so that's
really i just picked it because it was
the simplest case that illustrated all
these issues
and so that they don't look too
unfamiliar when we get to them that's
that's the real reason
[Music]
um i do have uh at least one question
uh are there any papers that would
actually look at
uh finite sample bonds uh
and confidence intervals for the max of
means at least for the gaussian case
and shows some kind of adaptivity i i've
been thinking about this problem
uh quite a bit and i haven't found
anything yet but uh
maybe there is something out there
if you assume if you assume everything
is normal
yeah uh i think you can i think you can
make progress in that case
certainly in a two parameter case i
think people have worked out what the
distribution is of the max of those two
means
uh analytically uh
i don't know if they've done it for more
than two uh
so that may be somewhere in the stars so
you could actually get the distribution
of
max of x bar one and x bar two
analytically
so there's a paper in like uh
it's in like transactions let's actually
sing so that
goes back to but that's the right way of
estimating things so think about when
the two means are
within this one over ten distance of
each other
uh then uh you would want to measure the
two samples
and to take the grand total mean and
then you would get much better
uh accuracy and and much uh smaller
confidence intervals so so i think that
that's that's
really the issue that you don't want
just to run with the max
of the two empirical means that's not
what i meant what i meant oh i see
okay yeah i misunderstood you sorry yeah
okay uh
i don't know if there's been much work
on this one one thing
i have seen i think at a talk at jsm so
this is pretty
recent stuff uh was this idea that like
um
they had not maybe this is helpful maybe
it's not sorry it's not that they had
two trials basically two samples
and then they wanted to detect whether
or not they they could combine the data
or not and they were taking a convex
combination of the two statistics
that was trying to be adaptive and they
were they were trying to deal with like
um sampling bias it's not exactly the
same problem but they were trying to do
that kind of
they were so it becomes a pooled
statistic in one case
and it becomes like just a statistic
from one in the other case so it's sort
of a related idea but it's not
quite what you're talking about i don't
think um
now i'm trying to remember who that was
yeah i'll have to think about it
yeah so i don't know i i think the
finite sample bounds are still pretty
open
as far as i know that uh but i can't i
could be wrong
okay pretty cool thanks
maybe should we pause on the live
streaming for now and then have
a 15-minute break before the next part
that sounds good i'm gonna go get a
sandwich